Kratos and boy I mean atreus are back
and they're ready to face the end of the
world together or at least I hope they
are here's everything you need to know
about God of War Ragnarok
[Music]
God of War Ragnarok takes place a few
years after the events of God of War
2018. if you haven't played the soft
reboot you might want to cover your ears
because I'm gonna recap the ending for
those that may have forgotten in the
final moments of God of War 2018 atreus
learned that he was part Giant and that
he has a mysterious role to play in a
prophecy where for some reason he's
called Loki in God of War Ragnarok he's
on a hunt for answers according to Sony
atreus is desperately curious and quote
like most young people he wants to
understand who he is more than anything
in this case he wants to understand who
he could be the mystery of Loki's role
in the upcoming conflict is something
that atreus cannot let go of that
conflict is the looming threat of
Ragnarok a prophesized battle that will
end the world and Sony continued by
saying quote atreus also doesn't want to
stand by and do nothing while the
conflict consumes the nine Realms so so
is The Game's subtitles starting to make
more sense to you now okay good as for
Kratos Sony says he is intent on helping
to spare atreus from the bloody lessons
he learned from his conflict with the
gods if you've never played the games
that came before 2018's release then let
me say this this man's hands get very
dirty we have a complete God of War
timeline available to watch if you need
a refresher for now back to Ragnarok in
order to find the answers they seek
Kratos and atreus will journey to each
of the nine Realms facing off against a
variety of Norse Gods and Monsters while
exploring stunning mythical landscapes
[Music]
at the start of Ragnarok Kratos has both
his Leviathan acts and the blades of
chaos giving you far more combat options
than you had at the start of the
previous game this has also allowed
enemy design to be more complex from the
get-go with Sony Santa Monica focusing
on providing both more variety and more
mini bosses for you to tackle some of
kratos's new combat techniques include
the ability to infuse both of the
Leviathan ax and the blades of chaos
with enhanced Elemental properties
depending on the weapon ice for the ax
fire for the blades doing so activates
new weapon signature moves which will
inflict massive damage on enemies
Shields will play a larger role in
ragnarok's combat scheme as well with
new Shield types affecting how specific
Shields can be used in battle some like
The Dauntless Shield are lighter but
excel at parrying While others as the
Stonewall Shield are sturdier and more
fit for slower combat absorbing damage
and creating a shock wave that knocks
enemies down when enough damage is
absorbed atreus and his behavior in
combat has also been updated to better
reflect his progression in character
with the trace being older and much more
confident in his offensive abilities
you'll likely see him chaining together
lengthy attack combos or initiating
enemies before you his range of magical
abilities also seem to give him an edge
in combat during an interview with Game
Informer ragnarok's Elite combat
designer chef and yeah spoke about a new
enemy type called the Grim a lizard-like
creature that stands on two legs both
designers also said areas will
repopulate with new enemies as the game
progresses so backtracking through an
area May reveal some new challenges when
it comes to accessibility features the
game's ux designer Milo pavlin explained
her team concentrated on four key areas
Vision hearing motor skills and
cognitive understanding back in May
Santa Monica Studio promised that God of
War Ragnarok would have over 60
accessibility features new to Ragnarok
are captions and subtitle improvements
which include increased minimum tax size
as well as extra large text to make them
even more readable colors are also
adjusted with seven different colors to
choose from returning from God of War
2018 are text and icon size options that
allow players to adjust the size of UI
text as well as make in-game icons
larger there are other features too like
a navigation assist that points the
camera in the direction of your compass
objective while not in combat a
traversal assist option that can
automate things like Gap jumping and
vaulting and audio cues that are linked
to various on-screen prompts which go
off when you're nearby a particular
interactable object
God of War Ragnarok is being developed
by Sony Santa Monica Studio with support
from eight other Studios these include
PlayStation Studios creative arts
Valkyrie entertainment blue point games
Red Hot super alloy jetpack interactive
Super Genius and original Force each
team's contribution to Ragnarok is
unknown though super alloy worked on
motion capture services for the game
Corey barlog directed 2018's god of war
and takes up the role of creative
director on Ragnarok Eric Williams who
has worked on multiple God of War Games
is taking the Reigns as director this
time around Ragnarok was originally
going to launch in 2021 but Kratos actor
Christopher Judge suffered an injury in
2019 that reportedly led to a delay to
2022 alongside judge Sunny soljik the
voice of atreus also returned for the
sequel however don't expect him to sound
the same team because just like his
character Sunny has grown up too other
cast members include Danielle bassetti
as Freya Ryan Hurst as Thor Richard
Schiff as Odin and Leia Hayes as anger
Boda just to name a few
[Music]
God of War Ragnarok will be released for
PlayStation 4 and PlayStation 5 on
November 9th 2022 with five different
versions available for purchase these
include two standard editions a digital
deluxe edition a collector's edition and
a yachtner Edition the standard edition
for PS4 costs 60 bucks with the option
to upgrade to the PS5 version for ten
dollars more the standard edition for
PlayStation 5 also includes the
PlayStation 4 edition and costs 70 bucks
so no matter how you slice it getting
both versions will cost you seventy
dollars the digital deluxe edition costs
80 bucks and includes both versions of
the game darkdale armor attire ax grip
and blade handles a digital art book
from Dark Horse the official digital
soundtrack and a set of PSN avatars the
collector's edition costs 200 and comes
with the digital versions of both the
PS4 and PS5 game a 16 inch replica
mjolnir Hammer a Dwarven die set two
veneer twin carvings an empty steelbook
display case the knowledge keeper Shrine
Kratos risen snow armor atreus risen
snow tunic and everything else included
in the digital deluxe edition the gotner
edition cost 260 dollars and includes
everything in the collector's edition as
well as a 7-inch vinyl a falcon bear and
wolf pin set a cloth map a legendary
drop near ring and a different set of
dice it's also important to note here
that both the collectors and Yonder
editions are completely sold out at the
time of this recording so happy hunting
and there you have it everything you
need to know about God of War Ragnarok
if you're in the mood for even more
Ragnarok content we currently have God
of War lore videos as well as history of
and timeline videos on the Gamespot
YouTube channel right now depending on
when you're watching this our review May
or may not be up yet but make sure you
check it out when it is available to see
what we thought about the game you can
find me on Twitter at Devonte Chisholm
thanks for watching
[Music]